welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's shang chi in the
legend of the tin rings
is one mcu title moving forward with
video showing the film's production in
australia
with major visual clues pointing to the
movie's mystery plot and what i believe
could be not only the movie's dark
opening scene but the
insane way it could blow open marvel's
future avengers story
in a post-credits scene now i've been
waiting to go into shang chi
aside from some bonkers theories about
tony stark's old tech
but let's now talk about this dude
spoiler warning though because i'm gonna
get into some rumored plot leaks nothing
you wouldn't be able to guess from the
comics mythology
stuff the cast and crew have said and
hot scoops from sydney's look
loose knifey spoony that's a green wool
sorry about that so shang shi is marvel
comics bruce lee literally he was
conceived as a martial arts hero
directly inspired by bruce lee's films
namely the massive hit
enter the dragon which came out months
before shang chi's marvel debut in 1973
chiang chi is the son of his enemy fu
manchu
and yes over the years marvel has had to
kind of course correct some of his
earlier depictions which the movie
adaptation now appears to be very
sensitive to
in front of and behind the camera
martial arts badass simulu is playing
the title role
after posting a long shot post on social
media saying he'd be down to do it which
we can do that because i will play
anything anything
i'm dying to be in the mcu please i can
act i
i've headshots i took improv classes i
know how to do it anyway one of
shangchi's recurring foes
is the mandarin also a big iron man
villain and this is where this becomes
very important to the mcu you already
know
mandarin is tied to the 10 rings of
power pieces of ancient mcluhan tech
that he recovered from
crashed alien wreckage each ring
possesses the spirit of an ancient
warrior and endow the wielder with a
different mystical power
yeah we're kind of talking infinity
stones language here but i don't think
marvel's going to go
right back in the direction of magic
jewelry tony leung will be playing the
mandarin
and shang chi and set imagery reveals
what i believe to be his
lair a large golden roof structure
surrounded by smaller ones and if you
look closely in the corner of that
compound
a dome that i think could be a fighting
pit or an
arena that could be the setting of a
tournament that the mandarin is involved
with more on that in a bit
now in the mcu the ten rings refers to
the network of criminal enterprises that
we've seen since the beginning
the tin rings was connected to the
terrorist cell headed up by raza and the
first iron man
and the guy who gave ivonvenko whiplash
forged travel documents in iron man 2
was a 10 rings operative and iron man 3
aldrich killian used british actor
trevor slattery to
pose as a fake version of the mandarin
but then in a short film all hail the
king
documentary filmmaker jackson norris
revealed himself to be a 10 rings member
with a wrist tattoo abducting slattery
from seagate prison to
answer to the real mandarin for stealing
his identity but you took his name
and now he wants it back
no sorry i still don't get it well
before we continue losing your hair is a
bummer two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're
35 we don't want that we'll get cold
well with keeps it's easier and more
affordable to get treatment for your
hair loss and help you keep the hair
that you have keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda approved
hair loss products out there but at half
the cost of your local pharmacy
and you don't even have to go to a
doctor's office you can do it all from
home
where you're probably stuck right now
you meet with a doctor online and they
ship the treatment right to your home
find out why keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly a hundred thousand men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication so if you're noticing that
you're losing your hair do something
about it for a limited time go to
keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description to receive
50 percent off your first order what a
deal that same tin rings tattoo
also showed up on the neck of one of the
interested buyers of darren cross's
yellowjacket tech in the ant-man movie
and if you've been listening closely
various clues dropped by these fellas
could signal this network's true agenda
raza lectured about the history of
genghis khan and asian dominance
the bow and arrow once was the pinnacle
of weapons technology
it allowed the great genghis khan to
rule from the pacific
to the ukraine a man with a dozen of
these can rule all of asia
and norris echoed this history lesson
you mean to tell me
that you don't know the history of the
mandarin himself
he was a warrior king inspired
generations of men through the middle
ages
perhaps even further back in time now
rumored casting reports speculated that
shang chi could feature
a ruler of a distant ancient kingdom
believed
to be genghis khan in this movie shown
via flashbacks with genghis khan being a
possible ancestor
of the mandarin himself whose origin
could be set during china's song dynasty
and the turco persian seljuk dynasty
another recent casting notice in sydney
is looking for archers suggesting that
raz's line about genghis khan's bows and
arrows might be a history we see in
shanghai aquafina is joining the cast
and social media posts from michelle you
and comedian ronnie chang suggest that
they'll be joining the cast as well
with some rumored casting of fighter
florian montiano
big nasty sarah finn rosalind chow and
fala chen
but it's not really clear if or who
these actors would be playing
but based on these set images and rumors
based on the movie's influences from
enter the dragon it sounds like a big
part of the shang chi plot will be a
major fighting tournament
see in enter the dragon bruce lee gets
invited to participate in a tournament
by the villain han
and encouraged by the british
intelligence to participate in it in
order to bring down han's criminal
operation the movie is
awesome and it's been hugely influential
not just on the character of shang chi
in the comics who has teamed up with
british intelligence mi6 agents like
clive resin
leko wu and blackjartar but it's also
been influential on all kinds of things
like street fighter mortal kombat you
know the stuff we grew up with these big
bonkers international tournaments filled
with diverse eclectic fighters
so with this movie it's speculated that
shanxi would have to enter this
tournament
either on behalf of the mandarin or
against the mandarin in order to
win the prize of the tournament the 10
rings of power
big nasty could be another warrior in
the tournament and shang chi could be
aided by the mi6
in order to stop the mandarin from
getting those rings you know kind of
like how in casino royale james bond had
to enter the poker tournament and he was
backed by mi6
and the cia in order to bring down the
bad guy and with shanxi and the mandarin
we're talking real bad folks because i
believe the dark opening scene to
introduce him
in the coolest way would be to have him
kill off trevor slattery the mandarin
imposter from iron man 3. just because
that comic-con kevin feige seemed really
clear that that all hail the king's
short was very important and in that
short norris made it clear that he
wasn't going to be the one who kills
slattery
suggesting the boss is going to be the
one to do it but then after that opening
scene i think the struggle many of us
have with this movie is how this martial
arts plot could fit into you know the
mcu a broader cosmic cinematic universe
set across galaxies and dimensions
one theory i had is that the ten rings
of power might be connected to powerful
rings we've seen throughout the mcu
like raza had a ring the king of wakanda
has a vibranium ring the sorcerer
supreme uses a sling ring
maybe neymar's got a ring made out of
coral and pearls you know but i still
suspect marvel studios isn't gonna go
back to
magic bling being a big deal however one
future plot they have teased
is secret wars the rooster brothers
themselves keep mentioning it in
interviews
promising that it's going to be an even
bigger crossover event than
endgame now secret wars is a comic
crossover in the 80s in which all of
marvel's heroes and villains
are teleported to an interdimensional
battlefield pitted against each other in
a tournament
by a figure called the beyonder so here
is my theory for shang chi
what if this tournament is being hosted
by the mandarin as a kind of bargain
in which he would get the ten rings of
power in exchange for earth's
deadliest hand-to-hand warrior the
victorious shang chi
hand it off to the beyonder to be
transported to battle world and spar
in a future avengers secret wars
think about it the beyonder could be the
villain behind the villain
teased in shang chi's post credit scene
the way thanos was teased in the
post-credits scene of avengers
this could set up the next avengers
crossover event in phase 5
making shang chi the warrior on the
front lines of it
folks shang shi is scheduled for may 7th
2021 hopefully we'll get a trailer by
the end of this year
until then join our nerdy discussion on
our official discord server by becoming
a patreon at patreon.comrockstars follow
me on instagram at eavos follow new
rockstars and subscribe for breakdowns
of everything you love and you know
yeah i i think i could play the beyonder
let's get the movement started
hashtag box for beyonder come on help me
out
[Music]
you